elle a 27 ans elle est née dans l'une
des villes les plus pauvres du monde
bombay en inde
et elle vit aujourd'hui un conte de fées
dans les rues de paris
depuis 8 ans bhavna pani sillonne la
planète comme vedette d'une comédie
musicale
ce spectacle qui triomphe désormais en
france s'appelle bharati sur scène
chanteurs musiciens et danseurs pour
tous de chatoyants costumes
traditionnels indiens
normal puisque le ch s'inspire
directement de ce cinéma qu'on appelle
bollywood bollywood c'est la contraction
de bombay et de hollywood
des films musicaux qui raconte à chaque
fois une histoire d'amour contrariée
des chansons mieres une multitude de
danseurs des couleurs flamboyantes un
cocktail survitaminé de kitsch et de
bonne humeur
[Musique]
sur scène bharati applique la même
recette
une idylle impossible cette fois ci
entre une jeune fille en costumes
traditionnels interprétés par bhavna et
ce jeune homme occidentalisée avec jean
et cravate
élevé en amérique c'est le choc des
cultures
dans un premier temps le père s'opposent
à leur mariage mais évidemment à la fin
tout s'arrange
cet univers typiquement indien se situe
à des années lumière de notre façon de
vivre en france personne n'aurait pu
croire que des parisiens blasé chauffé
par les artistes de la troupe se lève
pour danser comme des fous sur des
rythmes orientaux nique une jeune femme
de bombay serez acclamé comme store à
paris son destin batna le doit à cet
homme gâchage dash et 43 ans c'est lui
qui l'a découverte
le producteur du spectacle a tout fait
venir d'un enfant d'artistes bijoux
costumes et même cette moto entièrement
démontées et quatre personnes ont voyagé
avec des valises pleines de pièces
détachées arrive en france sur la tour
au monté avec un mode d'emploi comme
chez son drôle d'accent quand il parle
anglais ne vient pas d'inde mais
d'israël rien ne prédestinait gâchage à
monter une comédie musicale indienne
il était prof de droit à tel-aviv et il
n'avait même jamais mis les pieds en
inde
j'avais vu 2000 films de bollywood avant
de commencer ce projet
et un orange et en inde j'ai eu
énormément de lexus au pays j'étais déjà
amoureux de la culture indienne
puis sur place je suis tombé amoureux du
pays la première fois que gâcha je vais
en inde pour préparer son spectacle il
atterrit directement à bombay une
métropoles surpeuplées de 21 millions
d'habitants et surtout la capitale du
cinéma indien
les studios à trois quarts d'heure de la
vieille ville s'étale sur 500 hectares
on y tourne plus d'un millier de films
chaque année ces deux fois plus qu'à
hollywood ces décors reproduisent
parfaitement un temple hindou une maison
coloniale ou encore un palais des
maharadjahs
cette industrie fait rêver et pas
seulement dans les salles obscures
beaucoup de jeunes indiens veulent aussi
chanté et dansé sous le feu des
projecteurs quand gâchage a publié une
petite annonce pour recruter sa troupe
il ya huit ans il ne s'attendait pas à
devoir auditionné 3000 candidats en
trois jours
tous prétendent savoir danser pratiquer
les arts martiaux jongler ou chanter
[Musique]
et dans cette foule il détecte une perle
rare ban à 19 ans à l'époque
c'est elle qui va devenir la vedette de
bharati un bouquin elle va faire
sensation en occident vous avez vu son
visage elle danse depuis l'âge de 6 ans
et peut faire valoir une petite
expérience devant la caméra elle a déjà
tourné dans des publicités pour du
shampoing ou du soda mais aussi dans des
clips musicaux
le casting de bharati a fait basculer
son destin aujourd'hui quand elle n'est
pas sur scène à paris montréal ou prague
elles habitent dans les quartiers chics
de bombay bonjour
entrez entrez vous êtes dans ma maison
je vais ici avec ma famille vous habitez
encore chez vos parents à votre âge
oui mais oui je viens encore avec ma
famille parce que pour mon père je ne
partirai que quand je serai mariée à 27
ans elle habite toujours chez ses
parents
ou plutôt ce sont eux qui vit chez elle
car avec son cachet de bharati elles
gagnent dix fois plus que son père grâce
à son argent elle a pu offrir à sa
famille ceci pièce très confortable à
bombay c'est très rare de posséder un
balcon
les appartements sont généralement
minuscule mais bhavna a beau être une
vedette dans le monde à la maison c'est
une jeune fille docile jusqu'à son
mariage
batna et sous ma responsabilité c'est
moi qui lui dit c'est qu'elle doit faire
et puis une fois mariée elle fera ce
qu'elle voudra
pour lui aucun doute bave n'arrêtera
bientôt la scène pour fonder une bonne
famille indienne
en tout cas il ne regrette pas de lui
avoir appris la danse traditionnelle une
danse où chaque geste a un sens
l'essai par exemple j'attends mon
amoureux je suis fatigué de l'attendre
alors le soleil est tombé mais mon
amoureux n'est toujours pas là child
je suis fatigué et mon coeur cherche mon
amoureux et quand il viendra je serais
heureux à nouveau
la réussite de bave n'a fait rêver des
milliers de jeunes indiennes gâchage
revient en inde tous les ans pour
dénicher de nouvelles artistes car
régulièrement des jeunes femmes quittent
la troupe pour tradition oblige se
marier et faire des enfants
les candidates viennent parfois de très
loin comme cette jeune fille de calcutta
qui a traversé tout le pays pour
participer au casting
saft a pris combien de temps pour venir
ici de jeu et donner le voyage en train
aujourd'hui elles sont 70 ça passait
l'audition devant le producteur et la
chorégraphe les filles s'identifient
avec un numéro épinglé au t-shirt
les participantes ont souvent de beaux
diplômes mais bharati leur offre une
chance unique de voyager à l'étranger
je viens de bombay j'ai un master en
biotechnologies mais j'adore danser
alors pourquoi vous passez ce casting
parce que j'adore la danse et je
pourrais partir voyager en europe donc
c'est cool c'est surtout l'assurance
d'un bon revenu en un jour sur scène en
france
elle gagnerait l'équivalent de deux mois
de salaire moyen en inde
d'abord il ya la chorégraphie collective
sur un thème imposé pour une première
sélection c'est la numéro 5 qui s'en
sort le mieux
[Musique]
puis autour de la danse traditionnelle
qu'elles ont appris en quelques minutes
cet après-midi ce qui donne quelques
ratés pour la jeune fille en orange par
exemple
ensuite c'est l'épreuve individuelle la
numéro 6 tente sa chance avec de la
danse folklorique mais ce n'est pas
facile parce que pour la musique
elle n'a qu'un téléphone mobile la
numéro 5 elle a pensé à porter un cd ça
fait la différence
d'autant que la jeune danseuse et plus
hip hop que si tard pour gâchage deux
candidates sortent du lot aujourd'hui il
ya deux filles qui ont un bon potentiel
vous pouvez nous dire la une et la 5
c'est un mélange de plusieurs danses
faut qu'elle sache que danser le moderne
classique
ce premier casting ce n'est qu'un des
stars
le producteur doit encore auditionner 65
fille la une et l'a5 sont loin d'avoir
gagné leur billet d'avion pour la france
[Musique]
à paris au palais des congrès bhavna n'a
plus ce genre d'angoise cela fait 700
fois qu'elle monte sur scène
700 fois qu'elle se prépare en coulisses
elle se donne à fond parce qu'elle sait
que bientôt comme toute bonne indienne
elle devra mettre sa carrière entre
parenthèses
évidemment que ça va être un problème
quand je voudrais faire des enfants mais
je me laisse encore au moins deux ans le
public manifeste bruyamment son
impatience
certains artistes prix pour la réussite
du spectacle
il est temps pour bhavna de nous saluer
à l'indienne